hi there Steve Kaufman here video
casting and podcasting from the linguist
on language I'm going to continue doing
these video casts and podcasts from my
blog with the intention of providing
those people and we will provide
transcripts therefore for people who are
using these texts for language learning
I will announce that my blog where we
put the transcripts we may simply put
them on the blog I would certainly
encourage people to come to link Li ng
qcom if they need to work on some of the
vocabulary and the phrases and the words
and these texts that they want to learn
now I sort of have the wind in my sails
a bit on this whole subject of political
correctness and so I want to stay with
the subject and I want to I want to
first of all thank John B who commented
at my blog and supported the idea that
this is the subject of freedom of speech
very much belongs at a blog where we're
talking about language and it's
interesting that the person who has
criticized me for as he called it
ranting here and you know he was not
very flattering and his views about me
which is fine ah he felt that I should
just get back to the hardly more
language and that I you know he deserved
telling you what i should say here at my
own blog you know but no i think it
definitely has a place here besides
which i'm going to straight away from
the subject of language from time to
time just to cater to those people who
are interested in using my blog and
podcast and videocast as a language
learning exercise and we had some kim i
had some very nice communication from
tamara in Russia where they're using the
blog for their language learning she
sounds like a marvelous teacher so this
will help her and i'm sure it'll help
other people so the blog will provide
the different things for different
people i'll talk about language learning
but I'll also talk about other subjects
that I think are interesting now when it
comes to
I was learning or language let me talk
about this word language because I call
myself a linguist in the sense that I
speak more than one language and I feel
that anyone who speaks more than one
language or life's to speak more than
one language is a language to me now
David here who has been involved in this
polemic on political correctness he's
also a linguist but he's a linguist in
fact he might be a linguist in both
senses because he says that he speaks
more than on language he doesn't specify
and he also says that he's a philologist
which I had to look up in a dictionary
but apparently a falala gist is someone
who studies ancient languages whether it
be or maybe maybe not even ancient
ancient or obscure languages and
analyzes I'm not quite sure what he does
but he might tell us I don't know he
seemed to take offense that I even asked
him what he did and said something about
I shouldn't ask him for his credentials
or qualifications or something I don't
know why but he said ah but yeah I don't
underst I don't think I need to mention
my qualifications here he said okay he's
offended whatever but it's interesting
no so he said he's also linked with his
interest in the subject freedom of
speech and the tape that he has is that
free he says freedom of speech is a
right that has to be qualified when it
when it infringes other people's rights
okay but who determines what's a right
you know in the case of the Canadian
Human Rights tribunals Maclean's
magazine was brought before the Human
Rights Tribunal because they felt that
they print that an article printed by
McLain's had offended a specific group
Muslims they felt that the article was
not friendly to Muslims or somehow could
be construed or might give offence or in
fact did give offense because a group of
Muslims said they were offended but
that's not a hundred percent of all
Muslims in the world
were offended that's not even a hundred
percent of all Muslims in Canada that
were offended it's a couple of Muslims
who do they represent we don't know they
were offended or say they were offended
now is is it a right to not be offended
is that right I don't know David here
goes on freedom of speech does not
entitle anyone to use defamation to
provide false testimony in court or to
spread hatred well yeah we have laws
that govern that if you know libel laws
you know whatever telling lies in court
those are crimes and spreading hatred
now that's a difficult one because i
don't know i mentioned in my earlier
podcast about this David henick you who
certainly had many hateful things to say
was he spreading hatred can one foolish
old man in fact spread hatred I mean
it's not like he has an organization
that's marching in the streets he just
said something very stupid so but here
David Oh God political correctness is an
attempt to strike a balance what a
balance between what we have laws about
defamation we have laws about you know
telling the truth in court there are
some laws regarding hatred but I
hopefully they're directed more at
organized groups rather than individual
saying stupid things but David here
feels that somehow that it's the role of
political correctness and I guess he
would see him as as part of this group
of inquisitors who will decide and
certainly that's what the human rights
tribunals are trying to do in Canada
that they strike a balance you can't say
things you can't say that that a
particular group is is is bad and it
gets back to the earlier example I used
in Russia now they're going to have a
law that says you can't deny that
Russian Soviet the Soviet Union won the
war but it's being taken now by some
groups in Russia as an excuse to say you
can't criticize anything that was done
by the Soviet Army in the war because it
might offend people so now of course
getting back to the David he says now
doing you know striking this balance is
not censorship with nonsense of course
it's censorship if you call someone in
front of it
rights tribunal and say as they did in
the case of up of a person in Alberta
they say you can't this person Alberta
wrote a letter to a newspaper and said
that he doesn't approve of homosexuality
and he said it in terms that quite
frankly are no longer you know
persuasive with the majority people who
don't aren't as hung up about
homosexuality as this preacher is but
that's him and he said this thing now he
was hauled in front of a court and he
his final verdict was that he was no
longer allowed to write anything about
homosexuals and he was no longer allowed
to talk about homosexuals in his sermons
at his church and he had to pay five
thousand dollars to some gay lesbian
group the gay lesbian group said we
don't want this money we don't agree
with your decision we think freedom of
speech is the best protection of our
rights we can speak up others can speak
up we can present our position I'll this
present other positions that's how we
got the the whole attitude of society to
move on the question of homosexuality it
was through having freedom of speech and
challenging some of the established
values so they want no part of this
money so the Human Rights Tribunal of
Alberta gave the money to the plaintiff
the guy who brought the complaint he's
not a gay or lesbian he just he's he's a
a soul brother of David here the the
galloping politically correct vigilantes
and so he ends up with the money well
wow there's a way to make money so then
David goes on here he said he makes the
statement political correctness ie the
Human Rights Tribunal is not censorship
he says stop making such preposterous
claims well political correctness is in
itself not censorship because censorship
means that you actually have the power
to prevent people from writing or saying
things but political correctness is
exactly that it's the attempt to
pressure people into not saying what
they believe and not writing what they
believe and so that is a form of
censorship it's not preposterous this is
dispelled David is just a joke he just
used these words like preposterous he
describes as neural
ezra levant as despicable answer ezra
levant he said ra Levant le VA NT is
tremendous he won the award in Canada
for the best political blog he has won
awards you don't have to agree with him
but he's not despicable David just
because he doesn't agree with you don't
be so childish you and all of your
political correct politically correct
cohorts and anyway so blah blah blah so
I believe that we use language to
express their ideas we need to have the
freedom to express our ideas attitudes
within society move is only through
debate that they move and it's when you
try to suppress that he is such as
happened in the Middle Ages where we
weren't allowed to question whether the
Sun revolved around the earth etc etc
and that's when we end up with greater
injustice so that's if I hope I don't
have to get back to the subject we may
have Dave again but hopefully that's
lively and interesting to people who are
studying English thank you for listening